we
are so excited to be sitting down today
with an iconic actress
former model and toaster
madison brown from dynasty literally the
most chaotic most amazing show on
television this amazing show premieres
this friday we are so excited to have it
back in our lives welcome to the toast
madison
it's it's very surreal to be here it's
such an honor it really is such an honor
this show really got me through like the
pandemic times
so it's very exciting to be here thank
you for being here and thank you for
saying that and thank you for being a
toaster and also contributing to one of
the greatest shows of our time
i think oh my god wow such big dynasty
fans
and i'm so excited that it's coming back
what can we expect from this new season
what was it like filming in a pandemic
oh true
it's so we've been filming since october
so i feel like i've forgotten like
what's actually happened it'll be very
interesting watching it back
we like me and my co-stars i've been
talking about this all the time like we
literally have forgotten like what
actually goes on because
so much happens every episode yes and
this season especially
is crazy i mean like i really can't say
much because
you like your job that's my job yeah um
i'm very happy with my job
but um it's it's crazy it's crazy and
shooting in a pandemic just like added
another layer to the already craziness
of shooting the show like
we have a very hectic schedule as it is
um
and with the pandemic and all the
restrictions on top of that it's it's
been interesting and it was an
adjustment at first i mean i remember
the first few months
i didn't realize how much i would miss
like seeing people's faces
and not being able to hug people at work
has been quite
the adjustment who do you hug the most
my onset dresser lashon
so she like does all the final touches
like when they say rolling she'll like
run in and fix my outfit and she was
like
okay good the puppy energy in this
podcast studio is so iconic
it's so cute he's so cute i'm just
really scared of like
showing her teeth on camera that's gonna
be modifying but i i hug my onset
dresser lashon i think
the most um and i can't anymore but
she's really funny she's like adjusted
to the pandemic things so when she wants
to give you a hug but she can't she does
this
so she'll just look at you like this and
you like oh you want to give me a hug
right now but you can't excuse me
it was it was a hard adjustment the
first couple of months i think we're all
getting
as used to it as you can in these crazy
times
yeah these unprecedented times
um but you know like i'm just really
happy that
that they managed to make it work
because there was a real period there we
were all like
is this ever gonna like are we
and and again like we've spoken about
this a lot on the show
where we realized like in march last
year i mean we were shooting like a
crazy
episode we were shooting episode 20
which was like in a strip club with like
200 extras and background and everything
and sounds that's your website
super spreader event super spreader
event inside 200 people
and then like this stuff about covert
was coming and then there was like the
flight bound with europe and that's
and then tom hanks got it and then we
were like okay like now it's real
[ __ ] is getting real and the film
industry and entertainment in general is
usually
like unaffected by world crisis
crisis that happened but we were
itchy but hi cutie was uniquely impacted
by the pandemic and we realized we were
actually quite vulnerable like if this
is really like this this may never be
the same again and that was very scary
because
um it took them like we weren't working
we weren't shooting for like eight nine
months
and there was a real period there i
think after like three four months where
i was
personally very worried like are we ever
gonna go back is this ever are we ever
gonna be able to figure this out because
it was so
bad especially in la which is like the
epicenter of the film industry
yeah it was so bad and i was like how
are we ever gonna get back to work and
it was very scary
um but then we did and we have one of
our amazing producers
pascal and our unit production manager
kristin who just like
and our cco covert compliance officer
which is a new thing on film sets now
and they just like run such a tight ship
and touch wood
we want to i mean touch touch touch
touch touch wood if there's anywhere
nearby
oh we say knock on oh touch wood
touch wood wood we're one of the only
productions in the u.s that still hasn't
been shut down because of covert so like
we're running not
we're all vaccinated now so you know
we're like
not out of the woods yet we still have
to be really careful obviously but
um yeah they run a really tight ship and
i felt personally very safe and
and they've been very on top of it but
it was definitely weird at first of
course
is covet a storyline on the show no
thank god
i know and and and we all spoke about it
as
cast because we were like should it be
because it would make things easier as
far as getting back to work if we're all
wearing masks in the background but but
the thinking was like
you know we don't know what stage the
pandemic is going to be at by the time
it airs so like what if we're sort of
coming to the end of the pandemic and
then we have a whole season to get
through where everything's about the
pandemic like it just wouldn't
be and also i think again um
dynasty is a show that's very much about
like escapism and i just yeah
i think that you want to watch it
because you want to be distracted and i
think that's also why when it dropped on
netflix
in may of last year when the pandemic
happened it really blew up because it
was so
like removed from fantastical yeah and
just very everything's over the top and
it's really like its own like
hyper world where things are very
heightened and
dramatic and yeah so i think in
hindsight that was a good decision
i agree completely and i'm so relieved
to hear that we will not be covering the
pandemic in season four
yes because i've seen some other shows
where they've included it in the
storyline and they made it a big thing
and it's like i don't want to like watch
tv and be tortured if i want to be
reminded i'll just like switch on the
news
you know what i mean like i'll just like
read the new york times and be like okay
like
like the world is ending literally so
you're starting season four airs on
friday friday
you join the show season two yes now i
have a few questions the first is
how did you you just auditioned like how
did the process happen
i was in sydney at the time um i was
living in sydney
i just moved back from la and i
auditioned
with a self tape like sent it off to
casting in america
and then i got a call back and then we
did the test on skype
they had i think they had people in la
they were physically testing but i
couldn't make it in time so we literally
just did it on
like zoom um but it was skype before
zoom was zoomed
and um yeah then i got the part and and
it's funny because
i thought that he would only shoot for
like three months
i didn't like i was so green like i had
worked i had done a movie
and a mini series in australia prior to
that but i had never worked
in like u.s television like u.s network
television like 22 episodes
shooting for 10 months that was
something that i had never done and i
had no idea what to expect
so i get to atlanta like join the class
i'm at a car's dinner and i'm like yeah
like i'll probably be home by
like this was july i'm like yeah i'll be
home by like december and my
one of my co-stars sam matagoki who
plays jeff colby was like
um we shoot for nine months and i was
like
what he was like yeah you're gonna be
here for a while like
and we're probably going to keep going
so you're probably going to be here for
a couple of years and i was like
what i thought it was three months and
then like three years later i'm still
there and i think about that all the
time like i really had no idea like
what you're gonna be in atlanta for like
the next three four years i really was
like
three months like shoot the show go back
to sydney
like no and what is it like going from
sydney to atlanta
i mean the adjustment was it was
difficult at first especially because
where i was in sydney
i was really close to the beach i was at
the beach every single day
and i really i love like nature
but i do like i love nate like i love
being able to go to the beach
um wow i'm so proud that you said it
right so many americans say bondy
bondi let me tell you i watched a show
on netflix called instant hotel it was
such a bad show but one of the
characters they were australian was a
mother-daughter duo
and the daughter's name was bandai and
they were called bondai bondai
kept saying that around the house so
that's why i know how to properly
pronounce it
i'm sorry um yeah bondi that's correct
um i would go to bandai but i lived
i was sort of more like um north sydney
area like on the other side of the
bridge
and so i went to the beach like
basically every day
and so that was the hardest adjustment
um moving to atlanta because atlanta's
like
in inland um but then i got a
i got a dog and that really helped
because because when i figured out like
okay i'm going to be here for a while
like at least the next year
i got my dog poppy and that is that
really helped me
adjust sorry it's beautiful um but it
was it was difficult at first and
i had lived in la and i had lived in new
york prior to that
so i was kind of like used to the
america thing
and i'm a u.s citizen so i didn't have
to worry about any of that stress of
like trying to get here like that was
all taken care of but
um it was atlanta's different from l.a
in new york
yes it's it's it's they say it's like
the new york of the south but it's still
the south like
and so that was an adjustment but i i
got there eventually and i really like
atlanta like i've made a
i made in my little home it's really
like when i go back it's like
it's like a warm hug you know there's
it's kind of like a slower paced
lifestyle
and they say i think atlanta is like the
fifth most green city or like georgia's
like the fifth most green state in
america so like you really notice it
after being in new york or la when you
get off the plane there's just
trees and trees and trees for miles it's
quite pretty nice yeah
that's so nice um one of my favorite
things about
a dynasty is that it's so really like a
soap opera and like characters are just
so
interchangeable like what are we on now
our third crystal we're on our third
crystal
how many crystals have you been privy to
that's you that was my question
two because i wasn't in the first season
but i met
natalie like she was shooting the baker
in the beauty pilot in atlanta and so
everybody's talking about the bakery
well it went on netflix and now it's
like
i mean netflix is like they love the
soap operas
yeah but they love like a telenovela
style show in english
are these crystals let go because
they're fired or because they just love
changing the crystals seems like it's
now like an annual thing
well we kept the third crystal right
she's here to stay okay good
but i don't know about that i honestly
don't know what happened because with
anything else
why yeah and like they don't tell us
this stuff it's just like
another day another question yeah
exactly but daniella's doing a fantastic
job and
and we all make a joke like we finally
got one for more than one season like
week five she must be special yes yes
and the cast is also just like
littered with iconic actors left right
and center like you prob you
most of your scenes are with your dad
alan dale
who is caleb nichols caleb nicholl he is
uh
from lost he's literally been in
everything iconic everything's good
everything good that's how you know
dynasty is like a good show because alan
dale approves
yes what's that like i love alan and
when i joined the show
like he was one of the only other
australians and we just really
clicked like there's just something
about well he's actually technically
from new zealand he would shoot me if i
said he was australian because he's like
i'm from new zealand
okay sorry you're from new zealand um
but
something about like a fellow antipodean
you just really click and get along and
um yeah i love allen like no no bad
words to say he's he's great
and we grew up with him on the oc i
didn't even know he was from new zealand
yeah he's from new zealand wow that's
iconic well he was on neighbors in
sydney first he played kylie minogues
shoots in melbourne i'm so sorry um my
australians will shoot me if i get that
wrong
um neighbors shoots in melbourne home
and away shoots in sydney but he was on
neighbors
and he played kylie minogue's dad on
neighbours and kylie minogue's
um wedding on neighbors was like one of
the most watched television events in
history i think like oh wow yeah like
that's how huge the show was when he was
on it i'm pretty sure he played kylie
minogue's out i'm pretty sure that's
right that's so crazy because i
exclusively know him as caleb nickel and
he always just pops up as like a rich
older man well you know what's funny
is i was how i mean how old would i have
been when the oc came out but it but it
aired in australia like
just a little bit past our bedtime so i
never watched the oc
never ever until yeah yes until
when i joined dynasty i was like i gotta
i gotta do because everyone
like every time i post a photo with alan
or
all of my friends would be like caleb
caleb caleb like okay who the [ __ ] is
caleb like i have to [ __ ] watch this
show
and i became obsessed with it and i love
the ocean they were talking about doing
a reboot and like
if they do an oc reboot i'm gonna like
i'm gonna buy like the oc reboot much
like i'm gonna be like you need to
audition
yes i would love i would love you you
could honestly
be like well mersa spoilers here's the
pitch
seth's daughter now i don't know you
think
you could be like paris and ryan's love
child
well did you finish the show well i know
like what i'm gonna
spoiler alert i know like that's but
maybe she was like secretly like heavily
pregnant when that happened
and like someone like came in that is a
storyline that would happen on dynasty
yes it totally would
oh my god like the baby off the roof
story live or they're like it's a doll
it's a doll
no literally the story lines my favorite
is like how everyone was jockeying for
the
um like that found unlimited like
netflix subscription like they were both
competing and then like in the
next episode never spoke about it
totally actually my favorite moment is
um when adam is
uh in the dining room like losing his
mind and he pulls out a gun and
fallon just waltzes right into breakfast
and like literally does not give him
the time of day like even though he
fully has a gun wait what
yeah yeah i think i do the breakfast the
breakfast they're in the dining room
like having breakfast and he like whips
out a gun and just like waltzes right in
adam the brother yeah the crazy brother
can't stand him brother
i know but he's turning i think they're
trying to like make him more likeable
now
adam towards the end of last season like
you started like
yeah you can't say anything i don't know
maybe i don't know maybe you can answer
this that house
is it real is there any of it real so
when we shoot
outside like by the pool and like at the
front when a car pulls up
that's a real house that we shoot in in
sugar hill
in suwanee and georgia um huge huge
giant giant property like massive
but everything else like all the
interiors all the rooms in the house
it's all on a sound stage we have huge
sages
yeah there's like three full stages
full of sets like the kitchen the great
room like the stairs that you see
that's all the set that's cool i love
being in that the great room set because
we have like the stairs that goes
upstairs
right oh my god i love that set and when
i shoot in that set i really feel like
like wow i'm on dynasty and i remember
my first
um day not on the show but like coming
for a fitting
i got the pa to like show me around at
um the sets and i walked in there and i
was like wow this is crazy like
it's huge and gorgeous gorgeous
huge stunning beautiful sunset and it's
beautiful
the costume design is also sickening
like everyone's outfit do you get to
keep any of it
um i don't no no not yet i think
and like i've never been on a show let
alone a show that's been canceled and so
i think
if the thing like if the show ends then
i think
maybe we get to keep some of it because
they keep all of it in case we need to
go back and like do a flashback scene
they need to have everything
yeah sometimes and i like this about
dynasty like the characters re-wear like
the same pair of shoes oh i follow those
dynasty closet accounts yes
how amazing is that account you know
that's how good the fashion is on
dynasty like i don't
know what brand it is like literally
it's so
amazing she is so quick you'll show like
one
like they'll be like the sweater and
she'll figure it out their instagram
story like from set before the episode
airs and like she
will figure out what it is every single
thing from the tiniest bit like i'll
post i could like
something and i'll have to scribble it
out if i don't want people to see the
outfit because she'll
she'll find it she'll get it but it also
goes to show how the characters like
kirby like has boots that she wears like
oh the chanel boots
yeah that kirby wears i have worn them i
didn't even know like probably a dozen
times now i wear them
or like every second episode i'm like
should you do the chanel boots and
everything
aaron our costume designer is like fine
again i just
i'm just like it's just like again fine
okay
no it's really like one of the most well
done shows in terms of costume like it's
just fabulous
yeah i think the the costumes really
really make like elevate the show
completely agree because it's so
visually stunning to watch and like
our dps do such a great job like making
everything look beautiful the way they
light the house the way they like us
they the way they light the outfits it's
like it's a visually stunning show to
watch what i think is which i think is
also part of the appeal
and part of that like escapism because
it's so beautiful to watch i love seeing
rich people just do rich things exactly
and we got a new costume designer this
season so meredith was the costume
designer for the first three
costumes meredith costumes
we have a real fan here
should get security turns out i'm the
one running
the account isn't that a great account
at dynasty costumes
that's d-y-n-a-s-t-y
c-l-o-c-o
[Laughter]
is the show popular in australia like
when you get home
but i haven't been home since january
2020 right so i have
no idea what to expect i was being
occasionally recognized but i think
um people would be so shocked to see me
in australia because they probably
think like she lives in america but i
would come home and see my family every
christmas and so i'd be like walking
around
i remember i was at the grocery store
with my mom like in the suburbs where i
grew up
and these girls like chases up and down
every aisle and they were like what are
you doing here and i was like i'm from
here i grew up here
um but i haven't been home since january
2020 which is when like
the season dropped in may 2020 which is
when it really had that explosive
response and they released they released
the stats on netflix which they never
they never did prior and so it was
number one on australian netflix for a
full
week like number one out of anything on
australian netflix and so
i haven't been home since that um
and so who knows i i have i i don't know
if i would like be recognized more i
don't know um
that it's it's pretty big in australia i
know in france in the uk
it's huge and we're basically like the
beatles like if we were in france like
it would be
pandemonium like they shot an episode in
france and they said like there was like
fans waiting outside the hotel
like that level well that's what's crazy
like honestly a lot of the shows on
netflix i mean on cw
blow up on netflix like riverdale's
first season like became
hugely popular once it dropped on
netflix yes and
yeah yeah streaming is and and our show
as well people just binge watch it i
think yeah yeah
because it's that soapy you want more
you want to find out what happens it's
hard to watch one at a time exactly
because there's 35 different story lines
every episode
so you want to know like how how are
things going to go yeah
no it's so good and honestly like it's
just a really fun experience to watch
and you just really are kirby like i
have a hard time calling you madison
honestly
yeah right really yeah kirby kirby's
australian
and so i think you know how many uh like
tall australian redheads do you mean in
your life it's probably hard to separate
yeah but you bring a lot of yourself to
kirby i do yeah and we all do at this
point like we've been on the show now
i mean for me three years everyone else
for for almost five years now so it
becomes blended it becomes like a weird
like
who's 50 50 different from their
character good question
i think probably elaine who plays alexis
right love that she plays alexis oh yeah
but elaine is like couldn't be nicer
animal rights like dedicates her life to
veganism and animal rights at elaine for
animals elaine for animals exactly
she really is for animals and she has
yeah elaine couldn't be like
alexis is a little bit like not quite
together like scheming
like elaine is literally like the
sweetest nicest person in the world so
she's not like married
that was my other question was parent
trap big in australia oh yeah i mean
parent shop was like one of my sister's
favorite movies parent trap and
superstar which is also with
oh my god she's she's evian
yes evian at least my mom didn't name me
after bottled water
literally so she's such an iconic actor
she is she's iconic so
that when she joined the show i was i
was very excited yeah
did she talk about meredith blake and
avion at all oh yeah i mean like if you
see your instagram and her twitter like
she's like yes
meredith like it's me oh my god the room
is a truth
that is so i totally forgot she was
evian like that's literally one of my
favorite movies oh yeah you're horrible
oh my god it's just so good honestly
like you can't even explain it and that
must be so fun to work with her because
i feel like she's a delight
she's such a delight she's so fun to
work with and she's also really [ __ ]
nice
that's so nice to hear love to see it
always nice to hear
i'm sure some of the former alexis's
weren't as nice um
so so many there's so many um well
congrats on the four uh fourth season
yeah it's friday and the fifth season
now too
wow oh you got renewed yeah we've
already got a pickup but it's not
filmed we're not filmed yet we're we're
on like episode
17 right now i think of the next season
or episode of season four
episode 17. and then we'll
start shooting episode five i guess so
crazy i mean season five i don't know
what i'm saying that's so exciting
yeah if you guys haven't watched dynasty
yet treat yourselves binge it on netflix
the first three seasons are on netflix
you have what day it's monday right
tuesday it's tuesday
i've heard people that have seen a
season in a day so yeah you have no
excuses
it's just so good enjoy it and then tune
in friday night friday night
on the cw thank you so much for being
here guys thank you
so excited i have to give a quick shout
out to my friend montana as well she
like lived with me for a while
and we would watch the toast together
every morning and you think she's a big
fan so i
i can't like i don't feel right coming
in here and not being like montana
that's fair hey and thank you poppy for
being such a good girl
i was so worried that there was that she
was gonna no no
the two kids was gonna ruin her career
before it even began
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning shows we will see you
tomorrow goodbye
bye
you